hola a todos en este vídeo vamos a dar
una introducción a los campos
vectoriales ahora este es un concepto
que vamos a estar trabajando mucho en el
cálculo multivariable y la razón puede
ser que aparece todo el tiempo en la
física aparece en la dinámica de fluidos
y en la electrodinámica etcétera es
decir te los encuentras en todos lados
ahora lo que es un campo vectorial en
esencia es una forma de visualizar
funciones que tengan la misma cantidad
de dimensiones en sus entradas como en
sus salidas así que por aquí voy a
escribir una función de dos dimensiones
x james que su salida sea un vector de
dos dimensiones y que en cada una de sus
componentes de alguna manera me dependa
tanto de x como de gemma así que haré la
primera componente en igualar ya cúbica
menos 9 james y la segunda componente la
componente ya de la salida la voy a ser
igual a la función x cúbica menos 9 x
observa aquí hay un poco de simetría
pero no forzosamente debe de haber
simetría en las componentes de tu vector
y bueno si intentas visualizar una
función como ésta tal vez la primera
idea es que es un poco difícil de
dibujarla porque tenemos dos dimensiones
como entradas y dos dimensiones como
salida y entonces tendrías que encontrar
una forma de visualizar algo en cuatro
dimensiones así que lo que se hace es
fijarnos sólo en el espacio de salida es
decir solo fijarnos en el plano
xy así que para eso deja de dibujar
estos ejes coordinados este es mi eje x
y este es mi game y para cada punto de
salida individual sea el que sea que
tomes no sé por ejemplo tomemos el punto
12 voy a considerar ahora como salida a
un vector que va a estar anclado a ese
punto así que déjame calcularlo para que
veas a qué me refiero si evaluamos la
función en este punto 1 2
efe de 12 donde x es igual a 1 y es
igual a 2
entonces sustente el siguiente vector
héctor que tiene como primera componente
2 elevado al cubo menos 9 por 2 en la
segunda componente 1 elevado al cubo
menos 9 por 1 ok
y bueno si hacemos los cálculos esto me
va a quedar 2 al cubo es 8 menos 18
esos menos días déjame escribirlo por
acá
mi primera componente ya sabemos que es
menos 10 y 1 al cubo menos 9
eso es lo mismo que menos ahora déjame
ponerlo acá abajo menos 8 entonces ya
tenemos a este vector de salida y si lo
dibujáramos en el origen para que veas
me quedaría más o menos así es un vector
que caminamos en x 10 hacia la izquierda
hasta llegar al menos 10 y para abajo
aquí tengo menos 1 - 2 - 3 - 4 - 5 menos
6 -7 de hecho se sale de la pantalla
pero ahora es que es un vector muy muy
largo así que se vería más o menos así
observa se sale de la pantalla pero lo
interesante de los vectores
es que no importa en donde empiecen por
lo tanto puedo empezar en el punto 12 y
voy a tener una componente horizontal a
la izquierda de 10 unidades y para abajo
8 unidades 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 justo aquí
ahora observa que sigue siendo un vector
muy grande y en el caso de un campo
vectorial no tenemos uno o dos vectores
sino un montón de ellos imagina que
dibujará todos los vectores con sus
respectivos tamaños y además sus
interacciones esto me daría una gráfica
completamente amontonada hice un
desastre fíjate si lleno aquí de puntos
y de vectores y de marcas algunos
vectores que vayan por aquí y otros por
acá y en definitiva todo esto sería un
desastre así que en lugar de esto lo que
hacemos déjame borrar todo para que sea
más claro lo que se hace es escalar los
y al final se ven así observa aquí
tenemos una mejor forma para ver todo
aunque tal vez sea una pequeña mentira
de cómo son estos vectores en realidad
pero es que aquí tenemos más claro como
corresponden los vectores
puntos se ve todo mucho más ordenado y
bueno tal vez no sea completamente fiel
a la función original que tenemos porque
todos los vectores tienen la misma
longitud observa este tiene la misma
longitud que éste y que stem y también
que stem y en la realidad los vectores
resultantes de esta función son
distintos en magnitud pero esto es lo
que pasa en un campo vectorial sobre
todo cuando los dibujas con algún
programa de computadora ahora pues si
quisieras tener sus respectivas
magnitudes puedes hacer algo así
coloreando todos los sectores y mira
aquí tenemos otro campo vectorial es un
ejemplo distinto no es la misma función
pero puedes observar que aquí dibujamos
todos estos vectores para dar una
sensación de longitud a cada vector cada
vector tiene un cierto color y bueno
esto en lo que nos ayudan es que todo
siga ordenada observa que todos los
sectores tienen las mismas longitudes
pero colores distintos
en este caso el rojo y los colores
cálidos representan un vector muy grande
mientras que los colores azules indican
es más cortos ahora otra forma en la que
se pueden poner estos vectores es
escalar los proporcionalmente a la
magnitud que tienen observar este es
otro ejemplo aquí los vectores azules
son muy muy muy pequeños casi cero
mientras que los rojos son más grandes
todos los rojos tienen el mismo tamaño
aunque claro todo esto representa una
función en donde el vector original tal
vez sea mucho mucho más grande esta es
otra forma en la que podemos representar
un campo vectorial donde en cogemos o
agrandamos los vectores así que en el
siguiente vídeo voy a hablar un poco
sobre dinámica de fluidos para dar un
contexto sobre el origen de los campos
vectoriales y también es una buena
manera para ir conociendo algunos campos
vectoriales aleatorios y que entiendas a
dónde vamos con ellos